the goal was never to be skinny it was
um
it was never to fit into a certain dress
size
i i put a goal weight on there because
you know i needed some tangible thing
but i am really glad
that i did it because
[Music]
i think it was time like i'd been i've
been overweight for about 20 years
rebel wilson is getting candid about her
weight loss journey after shedding a
whopping 60 pounds yeah i'm good this
year i'm concentrating on health i said
that
yeah it's a year of health for me so
it's a slow
it's a journey but no i feel good
on tuesday rebel hit up instagram live
and revealed
all her tips and tricks starting with a
healthy diet
does this mean i eat healthy and clean
every day
no far from it but
i am prioritizing where i can if i go
out to a restaurant
i'll try the salmon a chicken breast
um i don't like i don't
eat much meat that's why it was hard um
i was mainly vegetarian
so i you know but now i really have to
concentrate on it because
my body just responds well to proteins
and she does some good old-fashioned
calorie counting
nutritionally the the only thing is
i do try to stay
under 1500 calories because again of my
my body type um if i want to lose weight
in that week
i kind of have to stay under the 1500
each day
um but now i'm going to go in more into
it like a maintenance phase would
probably be about 2
000 2500 because i i do
work out like a beast um
so i so i can eat a bit more um now that
i'm
now that i've hit my goal weight back in
january rebel declared on instagram that
2020 is the year of health
and she documented her hard work and
progress
ever since bloody brilliant getting to
it
the month before rebel kicked off her
year of health she told et
she lost eight pounds during four days
of filming cats
they heated up the set very hot to
almost 100
fahrenheit so that we could never cool
down
because for dancers these people are
like the best dancers in the whole world
so they can't cool their muscles down
they could get an injury and then they'd
be out of the film
so so they would heat up the set like a
sauna
and while the 40 year old actress says
she's reached her goal weight
yeah it's exciting she insists it was
never really about getting skinny
it isn't about a number on a scale what
what i was doing
is to improve my overall health and
and to improve my whole lifestyle to
make me a happier healthier
person i am really glad that i did it
because
i think it was time what i'm proud of
myself for is for doing that and
and having like a lot more
a lot more balance now
in my life another big reason to start a
health journey
rebel says it's the idea of someday
starting a family
i was thinking about fertility and
having good quality eggs in the bank
so i was like okay i'm gonna do this i'm
gonna get healthy
and how i started um is i did go to a
professional
place to do a detox the bridesmaid star
opened up about her relationship with
businessman
jacob bush and it turns out they've been
dating longer than we knew
he's a very private person so
don't don't like to give away too much
in in that department um
but i will say he um we dated
before before i started any of this
health journey um
as well as now so um goes to show you
ladies
you know to me a certain size to get a
boyfriend
you